Wieso? Okay, alles klar.
Guten Tag. Ich bin Dr. Gündo. Und in dieser Station als Assistentätig.
Ich würde gerne heute mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmegespräch führen. Wenn Sie damit einverstanden sind, können wir anfangen.
Ja, natürlich. Guten Abend, Frau Dr. Gündo. Hallo.
Guten Abend.
Soll ich in Deutsch reden oder soll ich in einem bayerischen Dialekt reden?
Bayerischen Dialekt reden ist besser für mich.
Bayerisch? Okay. Dann versuchen wir das mal.
Und wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Anne-Marie Seidel.
Können Sie die Vorname und Nachname bestäbieren?
Vorname ist die Anne-Marie Anton Nordvor-Nordpol Anton M.W. Martha Anton Richard Ida Emil.
Anne-Marie Seidel Siegfried Emil Ida Dora Ludwig Seidel.
Seidel. Heide Seidel.
Frau Seidel. Anne-Marie ist Frau.
Und wie alt sind Sie, Frau Seidel?
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
46? Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 23. Januar 1980.
1982.
80. Und wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ach Gott. Zuletzt habe ich mich, das liegt so länger zurück, gewogen.
Ich bin 74 Kilo.
Und bin circa 1 Meter 68.
Ja, Frau Seidel. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Sie ist zu uns?
Frau Doktor. Schön, dass Sie auch eine Ärztin sind.
Das ist mir ein bisschen unangenehm.
Ich kann nicht sprechen, aber von Frau zu Frau kann ich das besser machen.
Ja, natürlich. Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ich habe seit 2, 3 Stunden Schmerzen im Bereich der linken Niere hier oben.
Und ich muss sehr oft zum Wasser lassen. Und es brennt dann im intimen Bereich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es vaginal ist oder beim Wasser lassen.
Und ich habe so Koliken und Krämpfe.
Das ist schlimm. Manchmal denke ich, das ist wie die Geburt meines Kindes. Ganz schlimm.
Können Sie das wiederholen? Die Schmerzen?
Die kolikartigen Schmerzen sind manchmal ganz schlimm.
Wie bei einer Geburt? Ja, wie bei einer Geburt.
Wie schüttig sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 leichter und 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen sind.
Also das schwankt immer mal mehr, mal weniger. Im Moment geht es wieder ein bisschen besser.
Aber manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich auf der Skala bei 8 oder 9.
Im Moment eher bei 4.
Haben die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam begonnen?
Es hat relativ plötzlich angefangen.
Und sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen sie auch wieder?
Die kommen, die gehen so kolikartig, wie wenn es Wellen gibt,
die dann von der linken Seite in den linken Unterbauch führen.
Die Schmerzen in den Unterbauch?
Genau, im linken Unterbauch und manchmal in die linke Leiste.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Ich habe das Paracetamol genommen, aber es hat überhaupt nichts gebracht.
Hat das nicht geholfen? Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Wie viele Milligramm?
Wie viele ist das? Ich habe eine Tablette genommen.
Ich glaube, das sind 500 Milligramm.
Da habe ich zu Hause Novalgine gefunden.
Und da habe ich zwei Tabletten genommen.
In welcher Zeitung haben Sie diese alle Tabletten eingenommen?
Also Paracetamol als das erste Mal auftrat vor circa 4 Stunden.
Und Novalgine jetzt vor einer Stunde.
Danach ist es ein bisschen weniger geworden.
Mit der Novalgine? Ja.
Haben Sie die Enhäbeschwerden früher gehabt?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
Sie haben seit 2-3 Stunden Schmerzen im linken Nierenbereich.
Und begleitend fühlen Sie sich bremse beim Wasser lassen.
Und können Sie bitte genau beschreiben des Ürens?
Haben Sie verändernd das Ürens bemerkt?
Nein.
Kann das dunkel sein?
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Gibt es keine Blutblutblut?
Ich bin nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Fieber bemerkt?
Fieber habe ich bisher noch nicht.
Und ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig noch nicht, aber Schmerzen habe ich.
Leiden Sie unter Schweißausbrüche oder Schmerzen?
Nein, ich habe Schmerzen.
Und was ist das für ein Schmerz?
Das ist ein Schmerz.
Leiden Sie unter Schweißausbrüche oder nach Schweiß?
Oder in der letzten Zeit?
Nein, bisher noch nichts.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Bisher ganz gut.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollte Abworter zu genommen?
Nein.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Aber beim Wasserlassen?
Seit 3-4 Stunden. Vorher nicht.
Seit 3 Stunden.
Haben Sie oder ist Ihnen übel?
So eine leichte Übelkeit habe ich, ja.
Haben Sie schon mal ein Ruchen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Keine Schlafprobleme haben Sie?
Und Frau Siedl, möchten Sie etwas über Ihre Beschwerden helfen?
Nein, die sind manchmal ganz schlimm.
Ich bin jetzt hergekommen, damit Sie nachschauen,
was es ist und damit Sie mir etwas geben können.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Also bisher noch nicht, nein.
Und würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Ja, das war so eine kleine Operation.
Ich hatte mal einen Sportunfall,
an meinem Finger so eine Sehne genäht werden.
Aber sonst habe ich keine Operation.
Zieherfinger?
Der Zeigefinger, ja.
In welchem Bereich betroffen?
Oder welcher Zeit ist betroffen?
Rechts.
Aber hatten Sie keinen Bruch?
Nein.
Nur Schwierigkeiten oder?
Also da hat es geheißen, das ist jetzt ein Sehnenabriss.
Aber gebrochen war nichts.
Wie würden Sie behandelt?
Zuerst erstmal geschont und dann nach einer Woche hieß es,
es muss operiert werden.
Ich konnte dann meinen Finger nicht mehr bewegen.
Müssen Sie deswegen operiert werden, oder?
Ja, hat es geheißen.
Danach ist es besser geworden.
Haben Sie etwas geplant?
Wie?
Oder würden bei Ihnen eine Operation geplant?
Ja, damals, das war vor sieben Jahren,
da hat man eine Operation durchgeführt.
Vor sieben Jahren?
Ja. Nach der Operation ist es besser,
ich kann meinen Finger gut bewegen.
Sehr gut. Ich freue mich, das zu hören.
Gibt es andere Operationen bei Ihnen?
Nein.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Ich nehme keine Medikamente.
Ich habe bis vor kurzem noch die Pille eingenommen.
Aber das habe ich vor drei Monaten abgesetzt.
Haben Sie noch...
Oder sind Sie im Wechseljahr oder haben Sie noch regelmäßig?
Nein, ich habe noch ganz normal meine Regel.
Und ich habe auch einen Kinderwunsch.
Deswegen habe ich die Tabletten weggelassen.
Sie haben einen Kinderwunsch?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder und wir wollten noch ein drittes Kind.
Reagieren Sie allergisch auf bestimmte Medikamente?
Nein.
Oder Lebensmittel oder Substanzen?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Warum Sie verzeigen?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, sehr sehr selten, eigentlich nicht.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen oder haben Sie Kontakt für Drogen für Reagen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Ja, die sind glücklicherweise ganz gut.
Mein Vater hat einen hohen Blutdruck, deswegen nimmt er Medikamente.
Aber meine Mutter geht es gut.
Wie alt sind Ihr Vater und Ihre Mutter?
Mein Vater ist 69 und meine Mutter 67.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, der ist drei Jahre jünger als ich.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, so weit ich weiß. Der ist auch sehr sportlich.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Sind Sie verleitet?
Ja.
Haben Sie zwei Sohn?
Ich habe einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Mein Sohn ist 15 und meine Tochter ist 11.
Sind beide gesund?
Ja.
Und Sie sind noch ein Kind?
Ja, das ist mein Wunsch.
Hoffentlich können Sie diese Erfahrung nochmals...
Ja, das ist natürlich mit einem gewissen Risiko bei dem Alter.
Aber wir wollen es nochmals probieren.
Ich muss sagen, Sie müssen unter starker Kontrolle bleiben.
Ja, das heißt, dass das auch ein Augenärztin ist.
Vielleicht können Sie kontrollieren, ob Sie eine Betzwerge oder Vitamin D haben.
Nein, das ist nicht das.
Das ist bei der Ärztin. Sie macht das alles.
Sehr gut. Sie sind gut informiert, oder?
Ja.
Sehr gut. Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich arbeite als Projektmanagerin.
Und ich betreue dann verschiedene Projekte.
Das ist eine internationale Firma im Bereich der Automobilindustrie.
Bleiben Sie unter Stress wegen der Arbeit?
Ja, Stress gibt es immer wieder.
Und Sie haben eine Hauszene. Ich möchte eine routenmäßige Frage stellen.
Ja, wir haben eine Katze.
Und waren Sie im letzten Jahr im Ausland?
Nein.
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Ich meine, das kommt von der Kindheit.
Das war die Entscheidung des Kinderwunsches.
Unsere Hausarzt hat die Impfungen kontrolliert.
Es war alles komplett.
Alles komplett.
Ja, ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen, Frau Segel.
Sie haben seit zwei, drei Stunden plötzlich aufgetretene,
flanken Schmerzen, kann man sagen, oder?
Die linke Seite.
Und beim Wasserlassen fühlen Sie sich brennen.
Und diese Schmerzen sind wellenformig und krampfartig.
Krampfartig, kolligartig Schmerzen haben Sie.
Die Schmerzen-Intensität können mit acht bewertet werden.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in der linken Leiste.
Jawohl.
Sie haben Parasitemol und Novalgin eingenommen.
Mit Parasitemol hatten Sie keine besseren Kondensatoren.
Aber nach der zweimaligen Novalgin Einnahme fühlen Sie sich ein bisschen besser.
Ein wenig, ja.
Und Sie haben kein Fieber und Schwindel und Schmerzen.
Sie haben Schmerzen und leiden unter leichter Übelkeit.
Und seit drei Stunden Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen.
Aber Sie haben keine Veränderungen des Übens bemerkt.
Nein.
Keine dunklen Schmerzen.
Ja.
So, was ist es jetzt? Was machen Sie jetzt?
Ich habe meine Frage gestellt.
Aber natürlich ist es so, um die richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Wir müssen einige Untersuchungen wie Laborparameter prüfen oder durchführen.
Nach den Untersuchungen können wir über Ihre Beschwerden und die die noch mal erklären.
Daumen Sie langsam wieder.
Dauert das lang oder geben Sie mir noch mal was gegen die Schmerzen bitte?
Können Sie nochmal wiederholen? Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Dauert das lang.
Brauchen Sie lange? Weil ich habe wieder zunehmende Schmerzen.
Brauchen Sie lange für die Untersuchungen?
Ja. Sie müssen natürlich bei uns kurz bleiben.
Nach der Ergabense kann ich diese Frage gut antworten.
Aber leider müssen Sie bei uns kurz bleiben.
Dann machen Sie bitte jetzt schnell.
Ich bekomme langsam wieder Schmerzen. Ich möchte, dass Sie mich schnell bewegen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass diese Schmerzen mit ein bisschen leichter wurden.
Aber das war vorhin.
Ich kann Ihnen jetzt eine Schmerzmutter geben.
Das wäre sehr schön. Bitte.
Wenn die Schmerzen nicht unerträglich sind.
Sie haben keine Allergie. Deswegen kann ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmutter geben.
Allergien ist bisher nicht bekannt.
Ich habe mir eine andere Frage gestellt.
Das war's.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie überriechende Vaginalausflüsse und haben Sie auch Nierenstein vorgeschickt?
Nein, beides nicht.
Beides nicht, danke schön.
Sie haben vorhin gesagt, dass es das erste Mal ist, dass ich solche Beschwerden habe.
Hat jemand weitere Fragen?
Zusätzliche Fragen an unsere Patientin?
Ich konnte nicht richtig verstanden. Wann war die letzte Regel?
Was war die letzte?
Die Regel?
Ich habe bis vor drei Monaten die Pille genommen.
Die letzte Regel war vor zwei Wochen.
Vor zwei Wochen.
Entschuldigung, könnten Sie schwanger sein?
Das wäre natürlich toll, aber ich glaube noch nicht.
Die Regel war die letzte. Vor zwei Wochen.
Okay, keine Fragen mehr?
Ich möchte Ihnen heute unsere neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, kann ich anfangen.
Aber für Sie doch immer, Frau Doktor. Bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Anna-Maria Seidl.
Sie ist 46 Jahre alt und 23. Januar 1982 geboren.
1982.
Sie ist 42.
Sie ist 42. Wenn sie 46 Jahre alt ist, dann ist sie 1980.
Sie ist 24 Kilogramm und 1,68 Meter groß.
Wie schwer ist sie? 24 Kilo?
74 Kilo.
74 Kilo. Das klingt schon besser.
Das wäre ein bisschen wenig.
Die Patienten stellen sich bei uns wegen seit zwei, drei Stunden bestehende, plötzlich aufgetretene,
progrediente Flankenschmerzen am linken Bereich und Dysurie.
Der Patienten ist schmerzartig und welchartig.
Mittlerweile ist er schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit acht von zehn früher bewertet.
Aber zurzeit ist sie mit vier von zehn bewertet.
Sie klagte darüber hinaus, dass die Schmerzen in die linke unterbacht waren.
Sie hat einmal 400 Milligramm Paracetamol und zweimal Noval Gin eingenommen.
Aber das hat sie nicht so geholfen.
Die Fragen nach vaginalem Ausfluss und Obstpassion insomniere.
Die Schmerzen wurden verneint.
Die Vegetative anamnese waren bis auf Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen sehr unauffällig.
Sie hat vor drei Monaten eine Kontraceptive eingenommen.
Sie hat eine konservative Therapie abgesetzt.
Sie hat letzte Monate eine Kontraceptive eingenommen.
Sie hat letzte Regenblutung vor zwei Wochen.
Sie hat keine Möglichkeit für Schwangerschaft.
Sie berichtete, dass es keine Möglichkeit für Schwangerschaft gibt.
In der Familienanamnese leidet der Vater an arteriale Hypertonie.
Er ist momentan 69 Jahre alt.
Die Mutter ist 67 Jahre alt und ist gesund.
Sie hat einen Bruder.
Er ist 43 Jahre alt.
Sie ist verheiratet.
Sie hat einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Die beiden sind gesund.
Sie ist Projektmanagerin vom Beruf.
Sie arbeitet in der Autoindustrie.
Sie hat eine Katze.
Die Reiseanamnese war unauffällig.
Sie sind vollständig geimpft.
Ok.
Okay, was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Die analytischen Angaben deuten um Erhöhung auf
Urolithiasis hin
und
als differential Diagnose kommen die...
Ich habe sie nicht ganz verstanden. Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Urolithiasis, da Sie ihr Flanken schmerzen
und Kolikate schmerzen.
Sehr gut. Was ist Ihre weiteren Differentialdiagnosen?
Als Differentialdiagnose kommen die
Nephrolithiasis, Apandesitis
Eine was? Ich habe es akustisch nicht verstanden.
Oh, jetzt ist es durchgefallen.
Linksseitige Unterbauchschmerzen
Ach so, linksseitige. Ja, nicht Apandesitis.
Wie nennt sich diese Apandesitis auf der linken Seite?
Ja, ja, ja. Wie heißt diese Erkrankung?
Tatsächliche Astrucht, ja.
Aber wie heißt das, wenn der Darm entzündet auf der linken Seite?
Ja, Morbiskron oder
ja, krodische entzündliche Darmkrankheit.
Kennen Sie auch den Begriff der Divertikulitis?
Ja, Divertikulitis kommt in den Becken.
Also nicht Apandesitis, sondern linker Becken.
Divertikulitis, rechter Unterbauch ist Apandesitis.
Ok, gut, was noch?
Die Kolleginnen helfen Ihnen. Schauen Sie mal in den Chat rein.
Was kann noch gynäkologisch sein?
Apnexitis, schreibt die ja vielleicht.
Was ist eine Apnexitis?
Eine Enzündung, unter annexitis versteckt man eine Enzündung der
annexitis oder
der Ovaryan.
Ovaryan, ja.
Dreierstücke, genau, gut.
Ein Ovaryal cyst kann natürlich auch nochmal sein, richtig.
Was kann, na woran muss man noch? Eine cystitis, genau.
Eine pyelenephritis.
Und woran muss man noch denken, was Gynäkologisches?
Richtig, ein Ovarythrosyne, ja.
Oder eine Endometriose, an sowas muss man immer noch denken.
Oder Abdominal, wenn alles verklebt ist im Bauchraum.
Es hat keine Operation.
Eine Priage, stimmt, aber an sowas wie einen Bridenilius.
Wenn das Petitoneum mit der Darmwand verklebt ist und die Kämpfe bekommt.
Das ist halt sehr unwahrscheinlich, aber an sowas muss man mal denken.
Es gibt nicht Gewichtsverlust, aber es gibt einen Non-Rutschen in der Form.
Das hängt jetzt von den weiteren Untersuchungsergebnissen.
Ja, natürlich.
Was machen Sie da für Untersuchungen?
Ich würde zuerst eine astralische und körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Dann Blut abnehmen.
Und einige Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Und so wie ein TRP, ein kleines Blutbild, BSG und Nierenärte.
So wie in Kretin und GFR.
Harnsäure können wir kontrollieren.
Und wir können Rundstatus und Rundkarte prüfen.
Unbedingt, das ist das erste was Sie prüfen, natürlich.
Und, Atomzoller kann durchführen.
Ganz einfach, um zu gucken, ob es in einem Nieren aufstaut.
Und CT-Adumen können wir durchführen.
Zum Nachweis der Stein.
Das heißt Sie machen eine Computerdomographie mit Kontrastmittel oder ohne Kontrastmittel?
Ohne Kontrastmittel. Oder?
Mit.
Aber warum? Das ist keine Angebung.
Dann sieht man die Steine besser.
Ja, ich höre ja.
Bitte korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege.
Haben wir eine Randiologenautom?
Man kann natürlich auch eine sein.
Ich schreibe in unserem Dokument Januar direkt siehe.
Aber ich korrigiere hier.
Alles klar.
Aber man kann auch ein Nieren-Ausscheidungs-Urogramm, glaube ich, machen.
Ja, eine Urographie mit Kontrastmittel können wir durchführen.
Sehr gut.
Wunderbar, Frau Doktor.
Das ist Appendizitis und Divertikulitis.
Das ist, glaube ich, Ihre Aufregung gewesen.
Ja, am Anfang dachte ich, dass rechte Seite, ich sage linke Seite, aber...
Wir denken recht.
In unserem Fall, in Bayern, gibt es keine Divertikulis oder die andere Milieus oder...
Ich habe gehört von meinen Kollegen im anderen Bundesfall, dass es in anderen Bundesfällen viele Fälle gibt.
Wir sind nicht in vielen Fällen, aber ja...
Doktor, es ist schon ganz gut.
Sie sind ein bisschen nervös, ein bisschen aufgeregt, aber Sie wollen alles perfekt machen.
Das muss nicht sein.
Was ist eine Dextrakadie? Das kenne ich ja noch gar nicht.